good evening I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director here at the long now
foundation and just a few days ago we
hit a big milestone in membership here
at long now we finally surpassed ten
thousand members that have signed up
thank you and we we spent a lot of time
figuring out who gets to be member ten
thousand and so the answer we came up
with was that any member in good
standing is basically part of a drawing
that we're gonna do I think tomorrow and
so if if you're a current member you
have the chance to become member ten
thousand so definitely make sure your
current tonight when you go home and
you'll be you'll be in the mix good
evening I'm Stuart brand from long now
about fifty years ago the Apollo program
I rusty got photographs the Earth from
space got people off planet and we
started thinking of this place as a
planet and that introduced us to
astronomical time and may well be part
of why something like long now
foundation and thinking long-term and
all of that came to be both thinkable
and actionable and therefore it's
particularly appropriate to have as a
speaker tonight the britain's astronomer
royal who was also president of the
royal society which basically invented
modern science and so along with having
an astronomical perspective on
everything he's aware of all the science
going on and all of the technology is
spinning out of that and who better to
speak about basically the future of
everything then martin rees
well thank you very much Stuart it's a
great pleasure and privilege to be here
in front of this audience but hard to
follow that wonderful movie clip my talk
is going to be mainly predictions and
forecasts but I'm going to start with a
flashback to the Middle Ages inspired by
this Cathedral in Ely ten miles from
where I live for medieval people the
entire cosmology from creation to
apocalypse was just a few thousand years
they were bewildered and helpless in the
face of floods and pestilences and prone
to irrational dread they lived in
turbulent and uncertain times but they
built cathedrals this immense and
glorious building was constructed with
primitive technology by Mason's who knew
they wouldn't live to see it finished
and it still inspires us almost a
millennium later our horizons in space
and time are now vastly extended as are
our resources and knowledge but today
it's only organisations like long now
the think center is ahead this seems a
paradox but there is a reason the lives
of medieval people played out against a
backdrop to change little from one
generation to the next their children
grandchildren live the same lives as
they did but for us unlike for them the
next century would be drastically
different and we can't foresee it nor
plan for it
so there's been an explosive disjunction
between the ever shortening time scale
of social and tactical change and the
multi-billion year time span to biology
geology and cosmology a few years ago I
met a well-known Indian tycoon
you knew I had the title astronomer
royal as Stuart mentioned and he asked
do you do the Queen's horoscopes and I
responded with a straight face well if
she wanted none I'm the man she'd asked
he then seemed eager to hear my
predictions and I went took a straight
face and I said well stock markets will
fluctuate troubled in the Middle East
and things like that and he listened
sagely but I then came clean and I said
I'm only a scientist and astronomer and
he then lost all interest in my
predictions and rightly so because
scientists are pretty rotten forecasters
almost as bad as economists but not
quite are there no economists here so my
forecast will be very tentative
especially in front of an audience where
there are people with far more expertise
than me on each of the several topics
I'll address but 14 years ago I wrote a
book which I entitled our final century
question mark my publishers deleted the
question mark
and the America but the American
publishers change the title to our final
hour I guess you guys like instant
gratification and the reverse well that
book typecast me as a doom stir and
Luddite and I've tried to counter that a
bit in my new book advertised here by
offering some scientific optimism
despite political pessimism and the
theme is this the Earth's existed for
forty-five million centuries but this
century is special it's the first when
one species namely ours has the planets
future in his hands we're deep in the
Anthropocene we could irreversibly
degrade the biosphere or we could
trigger the transistor from biological
to electronic intelligence while
misdirected technology could cause a
catastrophic setback to civilization
we've had one lucky escape already at
any time in the Cold War when armaments
escalated beyond all reason the
superpowers could have stumbled towards
Armageddon through muddled and
miscalculation and that threat is merely
in abeyance nuclear weapons are based on
20th century science our focus later in
my talk on 21st century Sciences bio
cyber robotics and space which all offer
huge potential benefits but also expose
us to novel vulnerabilities but before
that let's focus on the long term
threats that stem not from conscious
decisions but from humanity's ever
heavier collective footprint because
here even with a cloudy crystal ball
there are some things we can predict for
instance by mid-century the world will
be more crowded 50 years ago world
population was about three and a half
billion
it's now about seven point six billion
and the gross been mainly in Asia and
Africa has shown in this map where
regions are scaley proportion to their
growth in the last 30 years but the
growth is slowing the number of births
per year worldwide actually peaked a few
years ago nonetheless populations going
up in some areas and world population is
forecast to rise to about 9 billion by
2050 that's partly because most people
in the developing world are young and
they're yet to have children and they
live longer the age histogram in the
developing world on the Left lots of
young people will become more like the
one on the right for Western Europe
where the birth rate has not increased
and most people live a long time and as
the upper part of the left hand one
fattens up that will give a big rise in
population even if the birth rate
doesn't go up and the main growth is in
East Asia and it's there that the
world's human financial resources will
become concentrated which will actually
end for centuries of North Atlantic
dominance and the other big change is
this more urbanization and to prevent
mega cities becoming turbulent dystopias
will surely be a major challenge to
governance population growth seems under
discussed partly perhaps because of
doom-laden forecasts by for instance
Paul Ehrlich and the Club of Rome which
proved off the mark
also some deem population growth to be a
taboo subject tainted by association
with the eugenics in the 20s and 30s
with Indian policies and Indira Gandhi
and more recently with China's hardline
one-child policy as it's turned out
country to the worst predictions food
production and resource extraction have
kept pace with rising population
that means still occur but there due to
conflict or male distribution not
overall scarcity but the capacity of the
world to cope depends on lifestyle it
couldn't sustain its present population
if everyone lived as prophet Li as the
better of Americans do today each uses
much energy and eating as much beef on
the other hand 20 billion could live
sustainably with a very ascetic quality
of life if all adopted a vegan diet
didn't travel lived in small
high-density apartments and interactive
our super internet and virtual reality
this scenario is fairly improbable
obviously and certainly not alluring but
the spread between these two indicates
it's naive to quote one headline figure
for the world's carrying capacity to
feed 9 billion by mid-century will
require improved agriculture low till
water conserving ham happy GM crops and
maybe dietary innovations converting
insects highly nutritious and rich in
proteins into palatable food and making
artificial meat really great new
technology and to quote Gandhi there'll
be enough for everyone's need but not
for everyone's greed population trends
beyond 2050 are harder to predict
because enhanced education and
empowerment of women
surely a benign thing in itself could
reduce fertility rates where they're now
highest but the demographic transition
so-called hasn't reached parts of India
and sub-saharan Africa on the other hand
if families in Africa remain large then
according to the UN projections that
consciousness population could double
again between 2050 and 2100 to 4 billion
Nigeria alone would then have as bigger
popular
as Europe and North America combined and
Africa's population will be nearly ten
times Western Europe's we're optimists
say that each extra mouth brings two
hands and a brain it does but it's a
geopolitical strains that worry me most
sub-saharan Africa can't escape poverty
as the so called Asian Tigers did by
undercutting Western manufacturing costs
these robots could do manufacturing now
and they may not have toilets but they
do have smartphones they know the
injustice of their fate they know what
they're missing and migration is easy
this is a recipe for instability for
multiple mega versions of the tragic
boat people crossing the Mediterranean
today so surely wealthy nations
especially in Europe should urgently
promote the growing prosperity in Africa
and not just for altruistic reasons and
another thing if humanity's collective
impact on land use and climate pushes
too hard the results of ecological shock
could irreversibly impoverish our
biosphere extinction rates are rising we
are destroying the book of life before
we've read it well ready there's more
biomass in chickens and turkeys than in
all the world's wild birds and the
biomass in humans cows and domestic
animals is 20 times that in wild mammals
biodiversity is crucial for human
wellbeing we're clearly harmed if fish
stocks tremble to extinction your plants
in the rainforests whose gene pool might
be useful to us but for many
environmentalists preserving the
richness of our biosphere has value in
its own right over and above what it
means to us humans to quote the great
ecologist ear Wilson mass extinction is
sin that future generations were least
forgive us for so the world's getting
more crowded under the second firm
prediction it'll gradually get warmer
now in contrast to population issues
climate change is certainly not under
discussed though it is I think we'd all
agree under responding to the famous
Keeling curve shows the concentration of
co2 and how it's risen over the last 50
years mainly due to the burning of
fossil fuels the seasonal oscillations
incidentally are because there's more
vegetation in the northern hemisphere in
the southern hemisphere so in the autumn
the co2 rises and leaves falafels trees
but what serious is this second arise of
course and v IPC see report and it's
update a few months ago presents the
spread of projections four different
assumptions about fossil fuel use in the
future etc and here are some of them
it's still unclear how much the direct
effect of co2 as a greenhouse gas is
amplified by water vapor and cloud cover
changing this so called climate
sensitivity is a further uncertainty
that's indicated by the bars on the
right which reach to the left
projections as an uncertainty due to the
uncertain science however despite these
uncertainties there are two messages
which most would agree on one regional
disruptions to weather patterns and more
extreme weather will even within the
next 20 years or so aggravate pressures
on food and water and enhance migration
pressures to under business-as-usual
scenarios we can't rule out later in
this century warming which is really
catastrophic and tipping poor
triggering long-term trends like the
melting of Greenland's ice so those two
things will be agreed but even those who
accept both of those statements have
diverse views on the policy response and
these divergences stem from differences
in economics and ethics in particular in
how much obligation we should feel
towards the long now towards future
generations the danish campaigner born
Lumbergh has sort of bogeyman status
among environmentalists slightly
unfairly actually but his Copenhagen
consensus a group of economists they
downplay the importance of addressing
climate change compared to shorter term
efforts to help the world's poor but the
reason for that is that he applies a
standard discount rate five percent per
year or something which in effect writes
off anything that happens after 2050 but
if you care about those who live into
the 22nd and Beyond essentially and
Beyond and all babies today can expect
that then as economists like vitamin at
Harvard argue you will deem it worth
paying an insurance premium now to
protect those generations against the
worst-case scenarios you wouldn't use a
standard discount rate so even those who
agree there's a significant risk of
climate catastrophe a century hence will
differ in how urgently the advocate
action today it'll depend on expectation
of future growth optimism about
technical fixes but above all it depends
on an ethical issue in optimizing
people's life chances should we
discriminate on grounds of date of birth
as the parentheses I'd note that this
one policy context where an essentially
zero discount rate is applied and that's
to radioactive waste disposal where the
depositors are required to prevent
leakage for ten thousand years or even
more somewhat ironic when we can't plan
the rest of
energy policy even 30 years ahead
consider this analogy suppose
astronomers had tracked an asteroid and
calculated that it would hit the earth
in 2080 63 years from now not for
certainty but we say 10 percent
probability would we relax saying it's a
problem that could be sat on one side
for 50 years people will then be richer
and it may turn out he's going to miss
the earth anyway I don't think we would
I think that'd be a consensus we should
start straight away and do our damndest
to find ways to deflect the asteroid or
mitigate its effect what will actually
happened on the climate policy front the
pledges that were made at the Paris
conference and renewed in Poland
recently are a positive step but
politicians won't gain much resonance by
advocating unwelcome lifestyle changes
now or high carbon tax when the benefits
accrue mainly in distant parts of the
world and decades into the future
uumm Claude Younker head of the European
Union Commission famously said in a
different context we know what to do
but we don't know how to get reelected
when we do it
and he's having problems with us Brits
this week as you probably know but this
one win-win roadmap to a low-carbon
future cleaner energy sources
I think nations should accelerate R&D
into all forms of low-carbon energy
generation and into other technologies
where parallel approaches crucial
especially storage batteries compressed
air pumped storage flywheels etc and
smart grids the faster these clean
energies advance the sooner will their
prices fall so they become affordable
too for instance India where they
certainly need more generating capacity
where the health of the poor is now
jeopardized by smoky stoves burning wood
and dung and where there will otherwise
be pressure for them to build coal-fired
power stations Sun and wind are of
course the frontrunners but other
methods have geographical niches
geothermal power in Iceland for instance
and tidal energy is attractive where the
topography induce especially large
amplitude tides and in fact in my
country
Britain's West Coast is one such place
and there are proposals for tidal
barrages and lagoons but because of
local intermittency especially a solid
wind we need continental scale DC grids
in Europe to carry solar energy from
Morocco and Spain to less sunny northern
nations and east-west to smooth peak
demand over different time zones in this
country and indeed in Eurasia and maybe
the latter shall be part of China's belt
and Road initiative and despite wise
ambivalence about nuclear energy I think
we should surely boost R&D into a
variety of fourth-generation concepts
which could prove to be far more
flexible in size and safer than the ones
we have now and the potential payoff of
fusion is so great at surely worth
continuing experiments and prototypes
it'd be hard to think of a more
inspiring challenged for young engineers
than devising clean and economical
energy systems for the world but if this
transitions too slow and if twenty years
from now our time it seems heading
irreversibly into dangerous territory
there may be pressure for panic measures
this could evolve a plan B being
fatalistic about continuing dependence
on fossil fuels but combating its
effects by either a massive investment
in carbon capture and storage or else by
geoengineering it's feasible for
instance to inject enough aerosols into
the stratosphere to cool the world's
climate sort of artificial volcano and
indeed what's scary is that this might
be within the resources of a single
nation even a single corporation and
they could be unintended side effects
and of course the other consequences of
rising co2 like ocean acidification
would be unchecked geoengineering would
be a political nightmare not all
countries would want to adjust the
thermostat the same way and the only
beneficiary will be the lawyers they'd
have a bonanza if nations could litigate
over bad weather there is a more benign
kind of geoengineering direct extraction
of co2 from the atmosphere this would be
there by undoing the Geoengineer who
then literally done by burning fossil
fuels but a recent report from the
National Academy emphasized that even
this relative benign policy has
downsides especially in its implications
for land use
if you plant more and more trees
incidentally I've talked about science
and I should emphasize that in doing so
I include engineering and technology
indeed the latter are what's most
important
and in fact my engineering friends like
a cartoon which shows two beavers
looking out up at a big hydroelectric
dam when beaver says to the other I
didn't actually build it but it's based
on my idea armchair theorists like me
should be very modest compared to those
who build things that work and meet
public demand and I like to say the
swedish engineer who invented a zip
fastener made a bigger intellectual leap
than most theoretical physicists will
ever do in their lifetime well we should
be evangelists for new technologies not
Luddites without them the world can't
provide food and sustainable energy for
expanding a more demanding population
but we need wisely directed technology
indeed some are anxious that it's
advancing so fast that we may not
properly cope with it and if we'll have
a bumpy ride through this century and my
book expands on these concerns where
ever more dependent on elaborate
networks electric power grids air
traffic control is national finance
just-in-time delivery and so forth
unless these globalized networks are
highly resilient their manifest benefits
could be outweighed by catastrophic I'll
be at rare breakdowns we are world
analogs of what happened in the
financial system in 2008 our cities will
be paralyzed without electricity
supermarket shelves empty within days if
supply chains were disrupted and
air-traffic ins we're a pandemic
worldwide within days and social media
can spread panic and rumor and economic
contagion literally at the speed of
light and by the way pandemics natural
ones could cause far more societal
breakdown now than in earlier centuries
English villages and towns like Ely in
the 14th century continued to function
even when the Black Death half there
population the rest went on
fatalistically in contrast our society
here would be vulnerable to serious
unrest as soon as hospitals were
overwhelmed and that would incur before
the fatality rates got anywhere near
even 1% advances in microbiology
Diagnostics vaccines and antibiotics
offer prospects of course for containing
pandemics but the same research has some
controversial aspects if he mentioned
two of these for instance in 2012 a
research group in Wisconsin and one in
Holland showed it was surprisingly easy
to make the flu virus more virulent and
more transmissible the somnus was a
scary portent of things to come and in
2014 the US federal government decided
to cease funding these so-called
gain-of-function experiments they've
been renewed now but with some
restrictions and the new CRISPR casts 9
technique for gene editing is hugely
promising but their ethical concerns and
worries about possible runaway
consequences of gene drive programs to
buy powered species as diverse as
mosquitoes may have been attempt to wipe
out the mosquito that carries the Zika
virus and some nasty people England want
to wipe out the grey squirrel which is
more successful in competing than the
brown squirrel is well back in the early
days of recombinant DNA a group of
biologists met in a cinema here in
California and they agreed on what
experiments should and shouldn't be done
this encouraging precedent triggered
several meetings in the last few years
to discuss recent developments in the
same spirit but today
forty years after the original Asilomar
conference the research community is far
broader internationally and more
influenced by commercial pressure and
I'd worry that whatever regulations were
imposed on Prudential or ethical grounds
on use of these technologies can't be
enforced worldwide anymore the drug laws
can wear the tax laws can whatever can
be done will be done by someone
somewhere and that's a nightmare whereas
an atomic bomb can't be built without
large-scale special-purpose facilities
biotech involved small-scale dual-use
equipment indeed biohacking is
burgeoning even as a hobby and
competitive game and we know all too
well the technical expertise doesn't
guarantee balance rationality the global
village will have its village idiots and
they will have global range and the
rising empowerment of tech-savvy groups
or even individuals by bio as well as
cyber technology will pose an
intractable challenge to governments and
I think aggravate the tension between
freedom privacy and security what about
another key technology robotics and ara
there are some concerns which are
relatively near term as the concerns I
have about biotech are but there are
deeper imponderables if we go further
into the future the smartphone the web
and their ancillary x' which are now
ubiquitous today for the sea magic even
just 25 years ago
so looking several decades ahead we must
keep our minds open or at least ajar -
transformative advances that may now
seem science fiction and clearly here I
can't make any good forecasts
but on the bio front we might expect two
things firstly a better understanding of
the combination of genes which
determined key human characteristics and
the ability to synthesize genomes that
match these features the great physicist
Freeman Dyson conjectures a time when
children will be able to design and
create new organisms just as routinely
as his generation paid for chemistry
sets well if it ever becomes possible to
as it were play God on the kitchen table
ecology and even our species may not
survive very long unscathed so what
about another transformative technology
robotics and AI here as I'm sure
everyone here knows there being exciting
advances in what's called generalized
machine learning deep mind and London
company now part of Google achieves a
remarkable feat its computer beat the
world champion in the game of Go there
he is and also did the same in in chess
and other games now this may at first
sight not seem a big deal because it's
20 years since IBM's deep blue beat
Kasparov the World Chess Champion
but deep blue was programmed in detail
by expert players in contrast the
machine that played go and chess
recently was given just the rules and
gained expertise by playing hundreds of
thousands of games against itself and
the programmers note themselves know how
the machines make some seemingly
insightful decisions and it is of course
the speed of computers which allows them
to succeed by the brute-force methods
and indeed to learn anything they don't
identify dogs cats and human faces by
crunching through millions of images not
the way babies learn they learn to
translate by reading millions of pages
of multilingual text
in Europe they're given EU documents
with their boredom threshold is infinite
and they succeed by reinforced learning
on these big training sets but learning
about human behavior involves observing
actual people in real homes or
workplaces and the machine would feel
centrally deprived by the slowness of
real life and will be the wildered to
quote Stuart Russell are leading AI
theorists here Berkeley I quote it could
try all kinds of things scrambling eggs
stacking wooden blocks chewing was
poking its finger into electric outlets
but nothing would produce a strong
enough feedback loop to convince the
computer it was on the right track and
lead it in next necessary action and
robots are still clumsier than a child
in moving pieces on a real chessboard
they can't jump from tree to tree like a
squirrel though a Boston Dynamics robot
called handle can do back flops
apparently but sensor technology is of
course advancing fast and even though
the go p-- playing computer used
hundreds of kilowatts of power the brain
of its human challenger uses about 30
watts just a light bulb and he can do
many other things apart from cosplay go
well what will a I do it won't just take
over manual work indeed plumbing and
gardening will be among the hardest jobs
to automate but it'll do
routine legal work medical diagnostics
even surgery and the big social and
economic question is this will the new
machine age be like earlier disruptive
technologies the car for instance
and create as many jobs as it destroys
or is it really different this time
well I think the answer that will depend
on economics and politics mr. money
earned by the robots will surely
generate huge wealth for an elite and a
few companies but I suggest in my book
to preserve a healthy society will
require massive redistribution of that
income to ensure that everyone has at
least a living wage this shouldn't be
just a handout but should be achieved by
creating and upgrading public service
jobs where the human elements crucial
which are now under valued and where
demand is huge
above all carers for young and old but
also custodians gardeners in public
parks and so forth but caring for the
old people is something where there's
huge demand that are met and it's
frankly a more dignified job for human
being than working in an Amazon
warehouse or in in a factory this
transition which requires massive deed
redistribution of wealth I could see
this happening in Scandinavia and in
China but there might be ideological
barriers in this country but let's look
still further ahead in robotics how
human-like will they be AI can of course
cope with fast changing networks traffic
flow electric grids etc and the Chinese
could have an efficient planned economy
of a kind that Marx could only dream of
and in science - perhaps AI can help us
to find the recipe for a high
temperature superconductor or settle
where the string theory can really
describe our universe because the
geometry is just too complicated for
humans to work through if robots could
not only do calculations but observe and
interpret their environment as adeptly
as we do they really be perceived as
intelligent beings to which or to whom
we can
and of course such machines pervade
movies and popular culture so we'd have
to ask would we have obligations towards
them we worry if our fellow humans and
even animals can't fulfill their natural
potential so should we feel guilty if
our robots are underemployed or bored
and what if a machine develops a mind of
its own but it's a ghost a ghost docile
or go rogue the popular culture portrays
a dark side where AI gets out of its box
infiltrates the Internet of Things and
pursues goals misaligned with human
interests or even treats humans as an
encumbrance some AI pundits take these
concerns seriously and think the field
already needs guidelines just as biotech
surely does but others like for instance
Rodney Brooks inventor of the Baxter
robots and the Roomba vacuum cleaner he
regard these concerns as premature he
thinks it'd be a long time before
artificial intelligence is a bigger
worry than real stupidity but be that as
it may it's likely the society will be
transformed by autonomous robots even
though the jury's out on whether
there'll be idiots afore or displays
superhuman capability
Ray Kurzweil the futurologist
now working at Google he argues that
once machines have surpassed human
capabilities they could themselves
design and assemble a new generation of
even more powerful ones and intelligence
explosion he thinks humans could
transcend biology by merging with
computers in old-style spiritualist
parlance they would go over to the other
side we then confront the classic
philosophical problem of personal
identity if your brain were downloaded
into a machine in what sense would it
still be you should you feel relaxed
about your body then being destroyed
what would happen if several
clothes were made of you and is the
input into our sense organs and physical
interacts with the real external world
so essential to our being this
transition would be not only abhorrent
but also impossible these are ancient
conundrums for philosophers but
practical ethicists may soon need to
address them
Kurzweil incidentally is a proponent of
the so called singularity but he's
worried that it may not happen in his
lifetime so he wants his body frozen his
blood replaced by liquid nitrogen
until immortality is on offer and he can
they be resurrected into some post human
world I'm surprised actually to find
that three of my British academic
colleagues had gone in for this
so-called cryonics - had paid the full
whack about $80,000 to a company in
Arizona and the third had taken the cut
price option of just having his head
frozen I'm glad they were all from
Oxford and not from my University and I
told him I'd rather in my days in an
English churchyard than an American
refrigerator
yes but of course more seriously
research on aging is being seriously
prioritized we have to ask here will a
band of his be incremental or is aging a
disease that can be cured dramatic life
extension will plainly be a real wild
card in population projections with huge
social ramifications but it may happen
along with human enhancement in other
forms it's at least surely on the cards
that human beings their mentality and
their physique may become malleable
through the deployment of genetic
modification and cyborg technologies
moreover this future evolution the kind
of secular intelligent design would take
only centuries in contrast for the
thousands of centuries needed for
Darwinian evolution and this is a
game-changer when we admire the
literature and artifacts that have
survived from antiquity we feel in an
affinity across a time Gulf for
thousands of years
with those ancient artists and their
civilizations but we can have zero
confidence that the dominant
intelligence is a few centuries hence
we'll have any emotional resonance with
us even though they may have some
algorithmic understanding of how we
behave and now I turn to another
technology space this is where robots
surely have a future and where I will
argue changes will happen fastest and
should worry us least during this
century the whole solar system will be
explored by swarms of miniaturized
probes far more advanced than the
wonderful Cassini designed in 1990s
which spent 13 years exploring Saturn or
the NASA pro or the ISA European probe
that went to this comet and landed a
robot on it or the NASA probe that sent
back these pictures of Pluto 20,000
times further away than the
and of course more recently of this
minor planet a billion miles further
away still think back to the computers
and phones of the 1990s when these
probes were designed and realize how
much better we can do today the next
step will be the deployment in space of
robotic fabricators which can build
large structures for instance giant
telescopes with huge gossamer thin
mirrors assembled under zero-g fees will
go for such an instrument incidentally
will be to resolve an image of an
earth-like planet around another star
and I think a nice target where we do
this by the Year 2060 eight the
centenary of the iconic Earthrise image
I showed earlier of our earth taken from
lunar orbit a picture of another earth
around another star we a new iconic
image but what about manned spaceflight
the practical case gets ever weaker with
each advance in robotics and
miniaturization so will it have a
resurgence its nearly 50 years since
Neil Armstrong's one small step and I
cherished this picture assigned for me a
few years ago by seven of the Apollo
astronauts in the 1960s there was of
course the space race against the
Russians NASA got about four percent of
the federal budget and had that pace
continued they've been footprints on
Mars long ago but once the race to the
moon was won there was no motivation and
I think the NASA budget is now by 0.6
percent of the budget but hundreds more
have ventured into space but under
anticlimactically they've done no more
than circle the earth in low orbits
mostly in the International Space
Station and this frankly only makes news
when something goes wrong when the Lu
fails for instance or when they or when
they perform stunts such as the Canadian
Chris Hadfield playing his guitar and
singing
so will there be any inspirational of
Paulo type projects in future there's no
denying that
NASA's curiosity and its recent
successor trundling across the surface
of Mars may miss startling discoveries
which no human geologist would overlook
but machine learning is advancing fast
as his sensor technology in contrast the
cost gap between manned and unmanned
missions remains huge NASA's man program
ever since Apollo has been impeded by
public and political pressure into being
very risk-averse
the Space Shuttle failed twice
in 135 launches each of those you
remember was a trauma and halted the
program for three years because the
shuttle had unwisely be proposed and
promoted as safe for civilians because
of this safety culture NASA will
confront political obstacles in
achieving any grand goal within a
feasible budget China has the resources
and the dearest government and maybe the
willingness to undertake an Apollo star
program it's already going to be
building a lunar base but it really
wanted to assert superpower status by a
space spectacular and to proclaim parity
with the US it would need to leapfrog
not just rerun what the US did 50 years
earlier and the clear-cut Great Leap
Forward would be footprints on Mars not
just on the moon but leaving aside the
Chinese I think the future of manned
spaceflight lies with privately funded
adventurers prepared to participate in a
cut-price program far riskier than
Western nations could impose on publicly
supported civilians
Elon Musk's SpaceX and Jeff Bezos it
blew origins will soon offer orbital
flights to paying customers were I an
American I would only support NASA's
unmanned program I'd argue the private
enterprise ventures being a Silicon
Valley culture into
main long dominated by NASA and a few
aerospace conglomerates should front all
manned missions as cut-price high-risk
ventures to be many volunteers some
perhaps even accepting one-way tickets
driven by the same motives as early
explorers Mountaineers and luck and the
future role of the national agencies
will be attenuated becoming more like an
airport than an airline and the phrase
space tourism should be avoided it lulls
people into thinking the touch bench as
a routine and if that's the perception
the inevitable accidents will be as
traumatic as those of the Space Shuttle
were these exploits must be sold as
dangerous sports or intrepid exploration
nonetheless by 2100 thrill-seekers may
have established bases independent from
the earth probably omaha's and musk
himself age 47 says he wants to die on
Mars but not on impact and he might but
don't ever expect mass emigration from
the earth no way in our solar system
office and environment even as Clement
as the Antarctic or the top of Everest
and here I disagree with musk and with
my late colleague Stephen Hawking I
think it's a dangerous delusion to think
that's based off an escape from Earth's
problems dealing with climate change on
earth is a doddle compared to
terraforming Mars there's no planet B
for all the reef risk-averse people
nonetheless we should cheer on these
brave space adventurers because they
will have a pivotal role in spearheading
the posthuman future in the 22nd century
and beyond this is why they'll be ill
adapted to their Martian habitat so
they'll have a more compelling incentive
than those of us on earth to redesign
themselves they'll harness the
super-powerful genetic and cyborg
technologies that will be developed in
coming decades these techniques will one
hopes be constrained here on earth on
Prudential and ethical grounds but the
settlers on Mars will be beyond the
trusses and regulators and we surely
wish them good luck in modifying their
progeny to adapt to alien environments
this might be the first step towards
divergence into a new species
so as these spacefaring adventurers not
those of us comfortably adapted to life
on earth who will spearhead the
posthuman era moreover if they make the
transition to fully inorganic
intelligence they won't need an
atmosphere and they may prefer zero-g so
it's in deep space not on earth or even
on Mars that non-biological brains may
develop powers that humans can't even
imagine few doubt that machines will
gradually surpass or enhance more and
more of our distinctively human
capabilities
as I said Ray Kurzweil and his ilk said
to be a few decades the cautious amongst
us imagine centuries but either way the
timescale for technological advances but
an instant compared to the timescale for
the win and evolution that led to
humanity's emergence and more relevantly
less than a millionth of the vast
expanse of cosmic time lying ahead so
the outcome of future technology and its
evolution could surpass humans but as
much as we intellectually surpass a
slime mold what about consciousness
philosophers debate where the
consciousness is special to the wet
organic brains of humans apes and dogs
might it be that electronic intelligence
is even if their intellect seemed
superhuman with still lack
self-awareness or inner life or is
consciousness emergent in any
sufficiently complex network so that
these post humans would still have it
even if electronic well some say this is
an irrelevant semantic issue like asking
whether submarines can swim but I don't
think it is this question crucially
affects how we react so the far future
scenario I've sketched if the machines
are zombies we'd not accord their
experience is the same value as ours and
the posthuman future would seem bleak
but if they're conscious we should
surely welcome the prospect of their
future Kemeny a word about the very far
future even if life had originated only
on the earth it need not remain of
trivial feature of the cosmos because
there's enough time for it to start at
aspera whereby ever more complex
intelligence spreads through the whole
galaxy far self-reproducing machines
transmitting DNA instructs for 3d
printers or such like interstellar
voyages or even intergalactic voyages
are not going to be Terror for near
immortals
but this raises the question which
astronomers are most often asked is
there life out there already we all
agree that we don't know
well not quite all I mean I and other
Tom's get letters from people who've met
the aliens been abducted by them and I
tell such people do they really think
that having traversed interstellar
distances the aliens would just meet one
or two well-known cranks and go where
again and also I say why don't these
people write to each other and not write
to me well where most of us don't know
but we know that there's no way in our
solar system where there's any advanced
life but there may be some simple eyes
that may be freeze-dried bacteria on
Mars there may be creatures swimming
under the ice on Saturn's moon Enceladus
but let's widen our horizon to the realm
of the Stars we've learnt that most of
these are orbited by retinues of planets
like the Sun is but the evidence is
mainly indirect we don't observe the
planets but we detect their influence on
the motion or brightness of the stars
they're orbiting and the special
interest in planets which are like the
earth and there are literally millions
of those in our galaxy and we can see
the nearest among them and some have
been found one of the most remarkable is
this object which is a miniature solar
system seven planets orbiting around a
very faint star an M dwarf and the years
for these planets vary from a
day-and-a-half Viana most to eighteen
days for the outer most would be any
life on on them
we have no idea they've very spectacular
places this is an artist's impression of
what it might be like to live on one of
them
viewed from one of these planets the
other would loom larger than our moon
does to us swinging fast across our sky
but their very own earthly they're
probably all tightly locked
presenting their same face to the Sun so
there'd be a sort of apartheid where
everyone lives in one half facing the
Sun except the astronomers who are in
the other half well all the evidence we
have for these exoplanets so far is
indirect detecting their effect on the
motion or brightness of the star they're
going around we'd really like to observe
them directly but that's hard to realize
just how hard an alien astronomer
supposing with a powerful telescope
looking at our Sun might be able to see
our earth suppose they could then the
earth would look like a pale blue dot in
Carl Sagan's nice phrase they close in
the sky to its star our Sun and the
billion times fainter but if the aliens
had the big enough intelligence that
they could be in a telescope that they
could observe this planet observer if
they could learn quite a bit about it
the shade of blue will be slightly
different depending on whether the
Pacific Ocean or the landmass of Asia is
facing them so they could learn as there
were continents and oceans the length of
the day something of the seasons and the
climate band lies in the faint lights
they conferred how to biosphere we can't
do this yet but the next generation of
telescopes can this is the ELT European
extremely large telescope they're not
imaginative here in element culture but
this is going to be the world's biggest
telescope 39-metre down to mirror that's
probably the width of this lecture hall
and that will be able to make
observations like I've envisaged of the
earth of Earth like planets around other
stars and to slightest
American telescopes will come online at
about the same time so this is going to
be a very exciting prospect in the near
future well they will find lots of
habitable planets where water could
exist but hable habitable doesn't mean
inhabited as most of us that's the
number one question we still don't know
the likelihood do we don't know how life
emerged on earth we don't know where
there was a rare fluke or where there is
inevitable we don't know what triggered
the transition from complex molecules to
entities that can metabolize and
reproduce moreover even if simple life
or widespread
we can't assess the odds that evolves
into a complex biosphere and even if it
did it might be unrecognized be
different but the question are we alone
fascinates so many that I think SETI
searches are worthwhile even though the
chance of success is small and I'm
actually the chair of the advisory group
for URI milliner's breakthrough
listen project but that's a topic for a
different lecture or maybe for the
question period so let me conclude by
focusing back closer to the here and now
to emphasize that even in these
concertina cosmic timeline extending
billions of years into the future as
well as into the past we are living in a
special century the first in Earth's
history when one species is empowered to
control the fate of the entire biosphere
to jumpstart a transition to entities
that far transcend our limitations or to
take a darker view to foreclose the
immense future potential and leave an
anarchic and depleted planet my book
emphasizes how our society is brittle
interconnected and vulnerable we fret on
Julie about small risks air crashes
carcinogens in food low radiation doses
etc but we're in denial about some newly
emergent threats
which could be globally devastating some
are environmental others owed the
potential downsides of novel
technologies which could cascade
globally in our interconnected world
innovations bring great hopes but also
great fears misterwives mantra the
unfamiliar is not the same as the
improbable so how can we forestall
catastrophes and ensure a brighter
future the trouble is that even the best
politicians focused mainly on the urgent
and parochial and getting reelected this
is an endemic frustration for those
who've been official science advisors in
government to attract politicians
attention you must get headlined in the
press and fill their inboxes so
scientists can have more leverage
indirectly by campaigning we need law
Carl Sagan type figures we can all
engage though by involved with NGOs by
blogging and journalism or through
political activities let me mention two
recent advances examples of how the
public has been influenced in 2015 there
was a papal encyclical which had a
worldwide influence in the lead-up to
the Paris climate conference saying that
humans had a duty to the environment
there's no gainsaying the church's loba
reach its long-term vision and concern
for the world's poor and the Pope got a
standing ovation at the UN and it had a
big effect on forging a census in Paris
and to take a UK example recently
there's now proposed legislation on non
degradable plastic waste this wouldn't
have happened without the
consciousness-raising images in david
attenborough's recent blue planet to TV
programmes and not if they be shown over
here in particular the image of an
albatross returning from wandering
thousands of miles in a Southern Ocean
and regurgitating was young not the hope
for nourishment the plastic debris
that's an image as iconic as the polar
bear on the melting ice floe
that certainly influenced UK politicians
to take ocean plastic seriously we may
be political pessimists but we must
surely despite all I've said proclaim
that these technologies can boost our
develops as well developing world and we
should not be too much concerned about
the downsides otherwise we never do
anything it because your principle can't
be carried too far and my book on the
future of some tentative hopes fears and
recipes and highlights the need to
assess which scary scenarios can be
dismissed the science fiction and how
best to avoid the credible ones we're
all on this crowded earth together
spaceship earth is hurtling through the
void these pastures are anxious and
fractious the life-support system is
vulnerable to disruption and breakdowns
but is too little planning too little
horizon scanning we need to think
globally I mean do you think rationally
empowered by 21st century technology but
guided by value that science itself
can't provide and above all we need to
think long term I've really highlighted
the world's religions and as all of us
here know secular organization the long
now foundation will create a symbol that
contrasts romantically with our
currently pervasive short-termism
in the cavern deep underground a massive
clock will be built designed to tick for
10,000 years to resolve with the
different chime every day over that
expanse of time those of us who visited
this century will contemplate a monument
built to outlast the cathedrals and will
be inspired to hope that a hundred
centuries from now it will indeed still
be ticking and that some of our progeny
will still be there to visit it and I
gave the very last word to one of my
scientific heroes the eloquent biologist
Peter Medawar
I quote the bells are topher mankind I
like the bells of our pine cattle
they're attached to our own neck and it
must be our fault if they don't make a
tune full and melodious sound thank you
very much for listening
[Applause]
I come with one question I'll get into
once and the cards here yeah you're
especially good an astronomical risks
and non risks and we have a couple
people from foundation b612 here we'll
make sure that asteroids will not be the
threatening thing that happened to six
million years ago and so we're probably
fine on that for the foreseeable future
as long as they get properly funded well
I wonder about comet's comets are so
unlike asteroids they come out and I've
heard some very bleak scenarios of boy
if a comet comes it's too fast it's too
surprising you can't do anything about
it and blam or dead yeah about that well
it's certainly the case that you can't
predict them so far in advance because
they come in from deep space and their
orbits aren't quite so predictable and
so it would be harder to to forecast
which ones are going to be dangerous
they're probably less likely than
asteroids but I think it's great what's
being done to identify asteroids and
risk their wrists because asteroids are
the risks that can most easily quantify
we know roughly how many they will be of
different sizes and what they will do
and and it's right that we do something
to reduce that risk but the important
point I'd want to make is that the risk
from asteroids is not any bigger
it's the same for us it was the
Neanderthals indeed for the dinosaurs so
it's nonzero but it's it's steady
where's the kind of risks that I'm
concerned about which I focused on are
those we are creating which are getting
bigger and bigger year by year and where
we don't have a long time base to assess
how likely they are and we can't be
complacent we'll survive them for the
long term so although we should worry
about the astronomical risks they don't
keep you awake at night it's the others
which are larger risks already and
growing over time
neutron stars things like that you're
setting off nearby and whether they
could happen but very unlikely here's
question famous last words
Nicky Glynnis it looks like says
national policy reactions are central to
a lot of your themes the human cause of
threats what do you think is the future
in the nation-state and all of this well
I mean that's that's very clearly some
of them have to be dealt with on the
global level I mean climate change most
obviously dealing with pandemics and all
these things and regulation need to be
global so we do need to beef up
international organizations or perhaps
have rather more along the lines of the
IAEA and the World Health Organization
to cope with all these things and of
course we have large companies which
transcend national boundaries so I think
we should have public service bodies to
do as well and so we certainly need more
of that so national boundaries are not
enough but of course to generate
enthusiasm for these goals camp has to
be done the national level and so it
could be that we can help our citizens
to activate our own politicians maybe a
state level or city level if not the
federal level and do that more
effectively than directly trying to have
a global effect the United Nations as a
result of a world war and there was a
sense of global threat that emerge from
that and the United Nations was a
response to try to keep a whole piece
going climate change is a global threat
quite a different order than the rather
episodic world origin is that headed in
the direction of the of a global
governance which is much more strict
than what we have now
well it needs it but of course the
problem of climate change is it it is a
threat is long-term
and as I mentioned you've got to have a
psychological discount rate which is low
in order to worry about it at all and
we've got to persuade people they do
need to think long term and care about
what may happen in the lifetime of
babies born today will be alive in the
year 2020 and so 120 and so I think
that's what what we need need to do but
as I say I'm pessimistic about the
traditional way of dealing with climate
change because they're asking for a
sacrifice now for this world to remote
and uncertain cold and that's why I
really do think that R&D into clean
energy should be prioritized on the same
level as defense research or medical
research so that we can really have not
just far cheaper more efficient solar
and wind but maybe entirely new kinds of
power and maybe new kinds of nuclear
fourth generation modular reactors and
things like that because if we just
focus on that completely it's a win-win
because the countries and places like
Silicon Valley if they develop these
innovations for clean energy and and
storage and superconducting grids and
all that then that'll be hugely
beneficial for them commercially but
also will help Indians to leapfrog
directly from smoky stoves burning wood
and dung to clean energy so I think that
should be the priority and that in my
view is going to be the only way in
which we really will see a reduction in
carbon dioxide emissions early enough to
make a difference
and I'm not an expert I mean III would I
better at least
even's if we'd have one power station
within 30 or 40 years but I just think
that in the context of 10 trillion
dollars a year being spent on engine
infrastructure then the few billion a
year being spent on fusion R&D is more
than justified but fishing as well
because the
designs doesn't use food the current
reactors of 40 or 50 years out of date
has been hardly any recent R&D what
happens after climate changes say it's a
century century and a half yes
problem one since I get sea levels we
keep rising for a good while yes
stabilize things so that is a kind of of
flux for generation especially people
are going into the coasts with their
cities so in a sense we're looking at a
continually changing earth even if we
get fossil fuel emissions and so on
under control how do you see that
playing out over time well I think if
it's slow enough we can cope with it
and I think the the other point is that
if countries get more developed then
they can cope with it like the Dutch
clearly can but clearly it's going to be
long term but I think other things we
need to worry about are going to be
whether the population stabilizes
whether the biodiversity etc so to be
all these issues because we were putting
different kinds of pressures on the
planet and some of them are going to be
very serious but climate change I think
we could deal with if we can get over
the next 50 years and avoid the co2
concentration rise into this dangerous
level where there might be a tipping
point as I say I think the only hope of
doing that will be very efficient and
they highly funded R&D and do you think
geoengineering to buy time for all that
to happen is a thing that I think should
be done yes I mean some people don't
even think that because yeah you know at
least a moral hazard people don't care
about the the others but I certainly
think we search should be done yes Kevin
Kelly yes how will science the
scientific method change by 2050 some
believe that significant discovery has
actually been slowing down lately the
trend is not toward more amazing science
but toward lots and lots of less amazing
so
yes yes well I don't it's true I mean I
think that's often said about particle
physics where indeed it is true but well
I mean I think there are lots of
particles but they're beyond the scope I
mean I think the cosmic dark matter is
particles but there may be a thousand
times heavier than could be detected by
any accelerator we can build that's
quite possible so it is truth in
particle physics the the only exciting
discovery in the last thirty years has
been about neutrinos but I think it
would be perverse to say there haven't
been huge discoveries in in biology
genetics and in astronomy exoplanets
knew nothing about them twenty years ago
most of all he knows the last few years
that that's a huge thing and we've
learned more about the very early
universe and not to mention all the rest
of science so I think the overall pace
of science is accelerating if anything
else because more people are active it's
true that the low-hanging fruits been
picked off and that's certainly true in
particle physics but I don't think it's
true in all fields and of course
computers help a lot of it I mean I
wasn't joking when I said that it could
be AI that would actually solve string
theory where string theory is extremely
complicated
lots of geometry in in ten dimensions
and maybe no humor can ever grasp it but
it could be that a machine the kind of
machine that could teachers have to play
world-class chess in three hours may be
able to do the calculations and see if
the particular version of string theory
does predict the proton has the right
mass and things like that so I genuinely
think that we can be helped by AI in
scientific projects and another example
I quoted was finding these sort of alloy
that gives you a room-temperature
superconductor this is a very difficult
to do just like you can test lots of
chemicals like in drug development but
this is where machines can help
acceleration I think in in some mistakes
could I make one point which is that the
may despite all that be some in
wasn't physical ideas which are just
beyond our human brain just like a
monkey can't understand quantum theory
there may be some fundamental aspect of
nature which were not even aware of and
couldn't understand if we were here 76
I'm here's a question about life don't
rub it in on the contrary wise
perspective has to do with your age you
know would you have been able to at the
age of you know 30 typical age here in
San Francisco have you had any of the
insight that you've been laying on us
today anybody here's a question it's
anonymous life extension including
cryonics means older adults today what
you can expect to be here in the 22nd
century very interesting statement if
people don't use a low discount rate for
themselves isn't that interesting as we
get longer lived people and that in a
sense long-term thinking comes with
longer lived people I think it does but
I think many people if they don't
conceive a long time they do care about
their children grandchildren and even if
people aren't going to live beyond 70 on
average then they know their
grandchildren will be alive in 22nd
century and I think that is what
motivates long-term thinking and they
would be unhappy if there was no world
200 years from now for their descendants
even though no one now alive would
realize what do was happening in the
world in the Year 2200 so I think it I
think we feel we're part of some ongoing
process and just as we realize that we
benefit from the heritage of earlier
centuries in the infrastructure and
literature and science and everything
else I think most will be unhappy if we
thought that there be no long term
survival of anything that we were
involved in so I think we do in some
sense do have a low discount rate in
some contexts
but no it's enough I agree with you
Isabelle Santa sex what about biological
carbon sequestration strategies about
expanding kelp yes help enormously fixes
carbon grass the questionnaire Astor's
lots more trees and there's some kinds
of air capture they know I mean I think
that was in the that's the cotton report
that I mentioned and I think it's
feasible I mean I think the two concerns
I mean one is that it's going to distort
land use which you need lots of land to
do this I mean but maybe algae or
something like that can get around on
that but but if you're going to use
trees then it needs lots of land and of
course this is a big problem of dealing
with the co2 the idea of having to sort
of safely store underground or somewhere
several billion tons of co2 per year is
not a trivial task and I think that's
got to be cope with it was well when the
hope is that you can sort of send the
carbon abyss in the ocean yes that's
what I do
I think below two and a half miles its
density is above that for water and it
sinks yeah science on land is pretty
thorough
we've been on land or land animals
ourselves my sense is that the oceans
this is a friend Jim love art it was
going out about this that our knowledge
of the oceans is pretty thin still and
yet it's an ocean planet it's a blue
planet and we don't know all the
processes going on there we don't know
all the life-forms there certainly we
don't know exactly how they were laid
right and the oceans are this enormous
event in terms of climate change and
what's your sense of the
role of ocean science especially under
the pressure of climate change we need
to understand more in the coming decades
well I think as you say it's crucial
that we've got to bottle the atmosphere
and the ocean is there the main store of
co2 and of course of heat and it's also
true that we don't done
have a good map of the ocean bed to the
extent that we have of Mars or the moon
and that does seem an anomaly so I think
we need to study those and of course as
far as feeding 9 or 11 billion people
then of course there may be a lot of
scope in the oceans and that's why I
don't worry particularly about feeding
people I guess the last question and
everything sort of bears relation to you
you know are you pessimistic or
optimistic or you know it's a scientist
you're used to stating things in terms
of odds and an error bar what's your
sense of the spa prospects of getting
out of this special century not only
alive but thriving hmm well very high
chance of being alive in a sense of the
most unlikely that anything to wipe out
humanity that a few things occur but
their boast unlikely but I think we will
have a bumpy ride I mean I I think that
governance is going to get harder for
reasons we're starting to see and
particularly because of unintended
consequences scientific developments and
above all the fact that a few people can
cause serious disruption I mean we know
that cyber attacks could be disruptive
the electricity grid in the city or the
whole eastern seaboard of the United
States things I have complete
catastrophe could be caused and even a
trivial case we had in England just two
weeks ago someone saw a drone over
Gatwick Airport and one sighting one
drone shut down out Airport for two days
and so just be easy because we are so
risk-averse and so interconnected that a
few people can disrupt society and I
think there's going to be a problem
making society resilient against our
sort of disruption that I think is one
of the main challenges to governance
we're going to have to face those weird
oh yeah well I can't wait for the rest
of the century that we get to see this
among the specialness is that it keeps
being full of surprises and that we not
really sure how it's going to come out
but we're looking at it from this cosmic
perspective that you brought and that is
formidable thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you